[Music]
huge story john travolta you probably
heard is embroiled in a sex scandal did
you hear about this yeah
appropriate noise for that thank you
everyone consulted their audience noise
book sex can not not whoo oh yeah I know
yeah yeah no I know I know I was saying
her name is continued this is the latest
a male massage therapist is claiming
that John Travolta sexually harassed him
yeah
yay apparently Travolta turned over
during the massage removed his towel and
told the massage therapist to get shorty
sound very proud of myself I'm so proud
of myself right I told the funny joke
today this is true story though the male
masseuse is claiming in court documents
that Travolta's penis is eight inches in
length yeah isn't that disgusting it's
2012 we're still not on the metric
system we have to get together
that's not right
I want to know in centimeters I I don't
know
whatever last night Rick Santorum
finally endorsed Mitt Romney for
president at 11 o'clock at night
yeah when reached for comment Santorum
said sometimes when I can't sleep I try
endorsing Mitt Romney for president just
puts me right house a pretty
half-hearted endorsement though that's
what people were saying today yeah
apparently Rick Santorum endorsed Mitt
Romney last night very late via email
yeah
this makes sent Orem the 10 millionth
guy to be ashamed of what he did late
last night on his computer
[Applause]
[Music]
right walking in it right but it's even
you endorsing Mitt Romney again you
better be watching porn yes I'm
endorsing Mitt Romney today president
obama's reelection campaign is focusing
very hard on Latino voters yeah that
explains President Obama's new campaign
slogan if you squint I kind of look
Porto Rican some people a little upset
with George W Bush it just came out that
taxpayers paid for president george w
bush's phone bill even when he was out
of office the bill was over eighty
thousand dollars yeah yep errantly bush
called for one one thousands of times to
ask if santa was real
[Applause]
we had a lollipop with the younger a new
report just came out it reveals that the
porn capital of America is now Orlando
Florida so proudly Disneyworld isn't the
only place in Orlando hiring dwarves
gotta bring up the Octomom the Octomom
has just finished shooting a porn film
she sought a porn movie yeah when asked
why she did it she said hey what's one
or two more people inside me
[Applause]
they looked up discuss